now sopra this is the entity adjusted
sopra what's going on with sopra sober
is our spent output profit ratio we're
looking at all the coins that are
trading on a given day the coins that
are being spent today you're looking at
the profit and loss that those coins
that are being spent today hold so if a
coin was you know bought at 50k it's now
being moved at 60k well that coin's
realizing ten thousand dollars of profit
if the coin was bought you know at the
pico top at 69k and then now it's sold
down here at 63k well it's realizing six
thousand dollars lost so you're only
looking at the coins that are being
spent on on each given trading day and
then you run the ratio between the
profit and loss and you get sober which
is spent output profit ratio
one is kind of that threshold where you
know if you divide one by one it's
neutral right so if the profit and loss
is balancing each other out then you're
at one uh above that the market's
trading in a state of profit below it's
trading in a net state of loss and so
what you want to see in bearish trend or
well in bullish trends is coming back
down and bouncing off that one threshold
on any kind of major correction and
bearish trends what you're looking for
is a failed retest from the underside of
one
and so what you'll see is
you can't see this on the chart but we
bounced off uh one in in september of
last year we had a continued uptrend in
the ratio
as you can see we had i didn't i didn't
label this actually but you can see this
bearish divergence where the oscillator
was making lower highs as price was
making higher highs
so that was kind of an early warning
sign we had this reversal broke down
below one
and that's what i have marked as that
bearish break so at that point you know
you can have a bearish bias but you
don't quite have absolute confirmation
yet um coming back down you know
that that initial failed break above
that range we were in over summer uh we
had that failed retest from the
underside of of one and now it's
confirmation that we were in uh kind of
a broader bullish trend um got a second
uh confirmation of you know the
underside test of one and then very
shortly after we actually got a bullish
break above one um and so from there
then you you know you have bullish bias
generally towards the market but we are
once again waiting for that confirmation
uh we came back down and retested 40k
about a month ago at the end of
september and that's when we got that
bullish confirmation now we're kind of
hovering uh you know a bit above one um
you know i would love to come down and
reattest um you know on some kind of
correction and hit that one threshold
but when you go back to last year i mean
after we had that re-test after
september uh we had like a 25 correction
right before the major
phase of the bull run at the end of last
year
and we never came back down and retested
one again we just continued an uptrend
so
what i'm looking for is
if we have a price correction to come
back down and re-test one in general
though i'm expecting this probably just
to trend higher and you know as we get
further into the bull run i would be
looking for another uh bearish
divergence as as you can see we had on
the left-hand side of the chart um you
know when we were in like april uh march
april kind of time frames when we look
at this utxo realized price distribution
uh you've got it squared off and you
said 18.36 percent of the supply why are
you calling that out and explain what
this chart's showing us sure so this is
realized price distribution so we talk
about realized price which is
the capitalization of bitcoin based off
the last time coins are moved so you
know with this in mind what this is
showing is
if a coin is last moved at 1 000 no it's
in the it's in the 1 000 uh bar volume
if it's then moved once again at 20k
well now it's pulled out of the 1k bar
and moved into the 20k bar so that's
where the realized aspect is coming from
you're so you're essentially looking at
where uh where each denominated at each
denominated uh price level how much of
supply has last moved there um and so as
you can see
above 50 i forget the exact number
because it changes as supply increases
of what exactly the price level is that
the 1 trillion market cap threshold is
but it's above 53k so i just cut it off
at 54k
but roughly 18.3 percent 18.36
um of bitcoin's money supply has moved
above that one trillion dollar uh
threshold and so to me that's showing
that there's confirmation from the
market uh well from marked participants
that this you know asset class is here
to stay um and that you know bitcoin is
is establishing itself as like a as a
maturing macro asset i think you know
that that 1 trillion
that 1 trillion threshold is kind of a
line in the sand as you can see that's
kind of where this cluster that we're
currently in starts
got it and when you look at this price
distribution uh that cluster what are
you looking to see happen over like say
the remainder of the bull market like
what is your expectation there um i mean
the way i just see it is like
by definition you're showing where a lot
of market participants or capital
inflows have come in so ideally like
these zones of volume are kind of
support or resistance levels because
they're they're levels where market
participants have interacted heavily
with so if you're coming up from the
underside to a large you know cluster of
of uh you know realized price
distribution and
saying you're probably going to face
some resistance some people that are
taking profits
and then conversely if you know for
correcting then you know i look for some
of these uh some of these zones as like
you know support levels uh on on on the
you know on a move down so uh that's
kind of the way i see it um but yeah i
mean this will definitely change over
time because you know you'll have coins
that are um you know
in whatever 40 50 you know and those in
those price levels that are going to
move once we go higher so you know this
is this is just something to to watch in
terms of like identifying where a lot of
this investor behavior is going on